at its early access baldur's gate 3 has
six starter classes available
and classes matter a lot more than they
did in larian's previous rpg divinity
original sin 2. but it's also not as
simple as choosing your virtual job
either
as the baldur's gate 3 character creator
follows a lot of the same rules as
classic dungeons and dragons
your character's race and the abilities
that go alongside your bloodline
also play a huge part in your build so i
thought i'd go through some of the most
effective combinations for each class
and race combo
from the start of the game up until your
third level for all those out there who
want to min max their experience
for fighters strength and constitution
are the stats to pay most attention to
starting as a gith yankee is an okay
choice as they have that plus two
strength
but i think the best choice is to go for
the shield wharf as they also have a
plus two constitution modifier on top of
their strength constitution being the
stat that affects health
so by combining both of those you have
an effective frontline melee character
who can also soak up a bit of damage but
also think about what weapons you want
to start with
dwarves obviously favor axes and hammers
while gith
are more effective with swords the
strength modifier is also going to get
you into melee combat more effectively
as it's the strength stat that affects
how far you can jump
which is a great tactic to get you in
and out of combat
the first level up is when you can start
to really build your fighter around a
roll
as this is when you can start taking
your traits do you want to focus on
protection
great weapons dual wielding etc
personally if i want to deal damage i
will go for the dual wielding option as
it will allow you to diversify the
damage output between different weapon
types and status effects
if you want a tank to take the damage
away from your squishy allies then i
recommend going down the protection
route and start planning ahead
to add some shield proficiencies this
level up will also get you an action
surge giving you an extra action with
every use
so be ready for those double hits and on
your next level up when you hit level
three
you get to pick between battlemaster or
eldritch knight going the eldritch
knight route basically makes you
a battle mage but with the current
roster you're already likely to have
some spellcasters in party
so i recommend keeping the focus on
melee that's where the battlemaster
option excels with some really good
passives
my advice is to swap out pushing attacks
and take riposte instead
repost grants you the ability to counter
attack which can be super effective with
two weapon fighting styles and the
downside to pushing attack is that it
has a chance to push
enemies away firstly if you're the tank
you want the enemies near you
and secondly it means you lose out on
the possibility of a reactionary attack
if the enemy chooses to flee away from
you
rangers have the option to choose their
favored enemy and an option for their
natural explorer perk a lot of this
feels like it will be more useful beyond
the act one which is what's included
in early access personally i think
players should either go for mage
breaker
which gives access to true strike
kantrip and some experience in arcana
for the second option i chose beast
tamer because it allows you to take on a
familiar these are pretty small
and squishy but it can be a good
distraction for enemies
as well as having some fairly decent
status effects like poison
or blindness be aware though at level 3
this is going to be pretty much
completely replaced
by something far better one strong
choice for race is wood elf for their
high dexterity and fleet of foot
abilities
but i think the better option if you
want to play that kind of stealth sniper
role is the lightfoot halfling
as they have high dexterity are stealthy
and have the race ability of lucky which
allows them to re-roll all ones
which means critical fails will be an
extremely rare sight for you
your first level up should be focused on
archery as the rest of your options here
are going to be done
much better by pretty much any other
party member you're taking with you
as for spells the most useful is going
to be ensnaring strike
keeping enemies a distance while you do
some damage and my other option of
choice is speak with animals because
honestly with all the story potential
you get from that ability it should be a
no-brainer to pick
whenever you have the option and for the
second level up the best ability to pick
is beastmaster now this is going to
allow you to summon larger animal
companions like bears and wolves into
combat
the options this gives you are great as
the summons are another damage dealer
with its own unique ability
and it's another massive entity to soak
up damage for essentially free
helping ensure the main party members
stay healthy
warlock is my favorite class it has such
a variety of options and weird spells
i think everyone should build one at
least once now for warlocks the primary
stat to pay attention to is charisma
as this is what they're going to use to
cast spells but high charisma is also
going to be super helpful when
interacting with npcs
outside of combat t flings and half
elves both have that plus two charisma
stat but as much as i love tieflings i
think half elf is a stronger option
as they also get an extra point to put
into two other stats of their choice
further helping diversify your warlock
you're going to have fewer spell slots
as a warlock so it's worth thinking
about how you're going to rely on your
cantrips and other basic weaponry
when it comes to your packs you have two
options you could opt into the great old
one
if you want battlefield control and
disables but if you want more melee
utility the fiend
will be a better choice personally i
went the strange cthulhu style route
as for cantrips i think the only really
essential one is eldritch blast
it's basically going to be your bread
and butter for ranged damage
and the more you level up the more
options you have to upgrade it dissonant
whispers and hideous laughter are both
great options for burst damage and
disabling your enemies for a few turns
and at your first level up you'll notice
there are a lot of options that relate
to things you already have i recommend
at least taking agonizing blasts to
upgrade the damage of eldritch blast
as like i said you're going to be using
that ability a lot
and beast speech again because it lets
you talk to animals and that's
never not been great spell choice will
depend on how you've built so far
whether you're going to focus on melee
range damage or control
charm person will help out here and
there and battle against humanoids but
for an option that's pretty much
always usable taking the hex enchantment
as a bonus
will make the rest of your attack sting
that little bit more level 3 grants
access to pact of the chain another
summoning ability
although rather than the normal
familiars you get to pick from imps or
quasits
much more powerful with much more potent
poisons than your average familiars
and for my final spell choice i'd say
either misty step for keeping you on the
high ground or if you feel like you need
a little aoe
shatter is a great option but again when
it comes to spells is really going to be
down to how you've played that character
so far
rogues feel like one of the classes that
aren't quite there yet when it comes to
what abilities and options are available
to you
but if you're playing one then i think
taking drow as your race is going to
give you the most benefits
as they both have plus two in dexterity
decent weapon proficiencies
and are the absolute best at seeing in
the dark which is going to be great for
all the
skulking around and backstabbing you're
likely to do one thing you should bear
in mind is that you need to be getting
behind enemies as much as possible
to take advantage of sneak attacks your
first level up is going to help you
there
as it's going to allow you to take dash
as a bonus action meaning you can rush
behind an enemy and still have the
ability to plunge your daggers in if you
want to mix things up come level 3 you
can add some spell casting by taking
arcane trickster
but again as you're likely to have a
spellcaster or two already at this point
i say keep to what you know and go for
the thief option
and continue to focus on stabbing spines
the thief choice will also mean you take
less fall damage if you're knocked from
your high ground hiding spots but fast
hands is the biggest bonus as it gives
you an
extra bonus action so that's either an
extra extra dash or more opportunities
to attack with your offhand weapon
just remember to stay mobile and keep
some melee backup or take buffs from
your mages as you're going to be a great
damage dealer
but awfully squishy with all the spells
wizards have as
options an exact build won't be that
helpful but i can tell you
what's going to give you the best head
start unlike every other class and race
combo there's nothing that will give you
a plus two intelligence trait which is
the wizard spell casting stat of choice
going human is fine as you get a few
other stat boosts but personally i think
the extra can trip you get from going
high elf
is much more appealing also elves are
immune from being charmed or put to
sleep
so this will ensure you can keep your
spell casters slinging lightning and
also a bit of elven dexterity for
dodging attacks
never hurt anyone i opted to swap out
grease and fog for thunder wave to push
away any bad guys melee rushing me
and magic missile as it's an extremely
reliable and consistent damage dealer
for the early game
first level up is basically a choice
between if you're looking to protect
yourself or deal some damage
evocation spells focus elemental energy
into powerful attacks and enchantments
and ab duration spells summon wards
banish enemies and nullify magic
evocation means you'll lose out on some
of the arcade ward abilities
and have to be a bit more precious with
your spell slots but you do get the
sculpt spells passive meaning that your
allies won't take damage from all your
spell flinging
so you can fire away with burning hands
with a bit more reckless abandon like i
said a full build guide isn't going to
help much for wizards especially when
they have
25 spells to choose from a level 3 so
what you pick here is likely just going
to be based on what you've enjoyed so
far
it is worth noting though that even if a
spell isn't in this list you can always
pay to learn it later
if you find a spell scroll and a handful
of gold although i must say again
for misty step having that is always a
bonus keeps you on the high ground and
away from
most of the danger i think the best bet
if you're going to play cleric is to
focus on life domain this is going to
make you an extremely powerful healer
and dealer of buffs also if you take
shadow heart along with you she's a
cleric of the opposite school
so you'd already be covered anyway i
opted to play as wood elf as it gave me
the biggest boost to wisdom
one of the most important stats for
clerics which is going to be very
helpful in the early game as you start
out with a very powerful spell and can
trip combo
guiding bolt and sacred flame the extra
stats are best served in constitution
and dexterity
especially if you're going with that
melee shield build that is so common
with clerics
these stats are just going to serve you
that much better if you're a frontline
battle party member the progression over
both levels is pretty linear
your focus should just be on buffs
protection spells and healing
as the other companions are going to be
pretty lacking in that department
by level 3 you should be able to keep
everyone topped up with hp via cure
wounds aid preserve life and the prayer
of healing and with the slots you have
spare taking spells like halt and hold
person will keep foes at bay
giving you a turn to dish out some heels
those are my choices for the most meta
or
min maxed builds to start you off in
baldur's gate 3. but honestly though the
character you should build
is the one you most want to play there
is absolutely nothing wrong with playing
a githyanki cleric a dwarven mage
or a human fighter it's a role-playing
game with such depth and creativity that
despite this build guide the best piece
of advice i can give you
is to experiment and be creative but
regardless i hope you enjoyed this video
if you did hit the like button and let
me know your favorite class builds in
baldur's gate 3
and what classes and races do you hope
larian adds next
until the next video you can find me on
twitter at irregular dave
and i'll catch you in the next one
[Music]
[Music]